When we have a less than inequality, we perform the same steps. f could be less
than positive 5, or f could be greater than negative 5. Remember, for the
negative answer, we reverse the inequality sign. And here's what's interesting.
The greater-than symbol creates a union, or two separate regions, where the less
than sign creates an intersection between two points. With just the flip of a
sign, we can exclude entire numbers or include a small region. And let's look
more closely right here at these 2. We said we get an intersection, so that
means f is between these 2 numbers. Let's rewrite these inequalities. Now that
I've switched the spot of these 2 inequalities, I'm going to reverse the
direction of this inequality. I've switched this inequality around, so negative
5 is less than f. This is still the same as F being greater than negative 5.
Notice the f's are in the middle now. The f's are between my 2 numbers. We can
even write this as one inequality, and, in fact when you solve any absolute
value inequality with a less than symbol you can write it as one inequality with
3 parts. Pretty impressive.